alors ils s'attendaient plutôt bien
aujourd'hui le maire de montréal denis
coderre et le chef de projet montréal
richard bergeron sont d'accord sur le
rôle du futur inspecteur général de la
ville françois cormier donc on a convenu
de modifications sur le projet de loi
oui parce que le projet de loi il est
porté par québec vous le savez pas
triste mais il ya des élections
provinciales qui s'en viennent alors en
faisant une entente comme ça avec
l'opposition monsieur commerce a su en
tout cas et c'est de s'assurer que son
projet de loi soit adopté avant les
prochaines élections provinciales
en gros ce sont des modifications qui
avait été demandée par l'opposition la
semaine dernière et monsieur coderre y
accède donc ce qu'on va modifier c'est
qu'il ya seulement le conseil municipal
qui pourra renverser une décision de
l'inspecteur général
auparavant il y avait aussi les conseils
d'administration des sociétés
paramunicipales qui aurait pu avoir donc
cette possibilité là mais là on dit non
ce sera seulement le conseil municipal
qui pourront renverser une décision
autre chose leur rapport de l'inspecteur
général
il sera remis au greffier de la ville et
pas juste au maire ce qui va faire en
sorte que tous les conseillers vont
pouvoir y avoir accès en même temps donc
effectivement le chef de l'opposition
s'entendent est plutôt bien avec le
maire colère aujourd'hui vous allez
l'entendre on peut être en désaccord sur
des points mais on a tous les deux souci
du bien-être des montréalais et montréal
alors je vous remets un jus remercie
publiquement et les chars de sa
contribution
chaque fois que ce sera possible c'est
comme ça qu'on va fonctionner
l'opposition officielle et le maire mais
je vous rassure tout de suite a atteint
compositions officielles ont été contre
le budget dans quelques heures
mais justement budget vote ce soir ça
sera pas unanimes non non ce ne sera pas
unanime donc monsieur bergeron l'annoncé
l'opposition va votre voté contre il ya
d'autres conseillers également qu'ils
disent ben on est plutôt en défaveur de
certaines mesures n'ont voté pour c'est
assez c'est partager dans certains cas
mais somme toute le budget devrait être
adopté ce soir durant une séance du
conseil municipal
merci françois avoir pas très revoir